i don't even have facial hair what the
[ __ ] am i doing
good morning and salutations another day
another vlog how is everybody doing
today i actually just got a text
not too long ago from fathead gilbert
himself today we're actually going to be
celebrating
uh alex acosta's birthday
actually gilbert is texting me right now
i'm
actually in the car and i'm about
15 minutes out
i tell people i'm 15 minutes out only
because
i want them to know that i cared enough
to leave even though
i really [ __ ] didn't
you guys should know who alex is by now
if you guys have been listening to the
podcast
alex is the homie from arizona who got
the most
[ __ ] hilarious freestyle that he made
when he was like seven or eight years
old
about his white shirt and shoes or
something [ __ ]
happy birthday guy look at this right
here boy
look at this right here boy hey i'm kind
of scared
thank you all right here we go i'm gonna
kind of fun time to take out my hat
you know what you know which song we
want right you know which song we want
right
with that i don't know the line hey
people look at me
like i look like her forget them fool i
ain't no fool yeah i ride i know i'm 24
i was on my way to school
no i ain't black but i ain't white ass
no i get a lot of stuff like i lost my
toe got a lot of friends got a lot of
money
i don't like sugar but i like i'm in
sixth grade so i ain't that smart so my
favorite kind of food is a cherry pop
tart
i'm four foot eight so i'm not that tall
so in that bathroom my pee and i stall
now i know how to sing
the abcs i'm lactose intolerant so i
don't eat cheese
my man from arizona got that lake
korean girl fell out
i've been trying to do this thing lately
where i'm saying positive things about
myself in the morning
i'm someone who tends to be very
critical about myself meaning that the
moment that i wake up i'm thinking about
stuff that i either have to fix about
myself that i have to work on
and though a lot of the times people
might derive a lot of strength from that
which is
you know i think that's how i used to
function sometimes you just got to give
yourself a pep talk
you got a lot of things going for you
david god made your body a little lumpy
but he made that heart fool you know
what i'm saying what's this fat pimple i
have on my face what the [ __ ]
knees weak arms are heavy he wrote
spaghetti spaghetti
and the reason why i started doing this
is because i genuinely believe there's
enough people out in this
world that's going to break you down you
might as well be the first person to
lift you up in the morning then you know
what i'm saying
but let's go ahead and get this day
started my friends
i am going to take y'all on a food
adventure now there is a restaurant
in los angeles that i heard make some of
the
best food at lightning speed and i heard
through the grapevine there's a couple
of things on their seasonal menu that
just popped up that we
absolutely have to try
hi can i get the uh a 20-piece spicy
nugget
uh let's do the sweet and sour and also
the barbecue and then i'll also do the
uh the travis scott meal
oh mcdonald's i'm telling you yes it's
it's
it's fancy you know what i'm saying
listen i don't give a [ __ ] what y'all
say some of y'all out there they're like
oh my god you eat such
good food how can you go back to
mcdonald's how can i go back
to mcdonald's i never left [ __ ] but yo
so check it out
so mcdonald's has this travis scott meal
that came out but the travis got meal is
a quarter pounder with bacon added to it
my god look at this look at this bad boy
and i gotta tell you i don't know if
because
homegirl who recognized me hooked it up
but this looks
amazing well you could be in a youtube
video right here look at that
hi how are you
that was so cool come by more often out
of all the places i could get recognized
it would be
a mcdonald's why so a quarter pounder
apparently is supposed to be
a quarter pound of beef and this thing
has double cheese bacon
shredded lettuce and uh all american
cheese and ketchup and everything else
like that it looks
really really [ __ ] good let's go
ahead and bite into this bad boy
okay yo i haven't had a quarter pound in
a hot minute but yo
that's just [ __ ] fire okay
soft-ass sesame bun you ain't playing
with me
apparently travis scott likes to eat his
[ __ ] with um tangy barbecue sauce as
well
this bacon with the barbecue sauce like
that
okay having this with the barbecue sauce
right now
travis scott you know what's up with the
bacon
and the bro you playing with me right
now
you ain't even fat now this is what i'm
really here for
oh [ __ ] spicy chicken nuggets what's up
this is so interesting first of all
i typically don't want anybody [ __ ]
with my chicken nuggets
back in the day mcdonald's did change up
the recipe on the nugget they decided to
make it all white meat which i didn't
really appreciate but the flavor was
still there so
i was good with it i'm not sure if they
went back to the original formula but
they're still popping chicken nuggets
are the best fast food nuggets out there
hands down wendy's burger king y'all all
right
but still when it comes to a chicken
nugget you don't beat mcdonald's
especially with the sweet and sour
arigato
let's give this a go
i'm not mad at it it doesn't taste bad
but it doesn't taste as good as the
original chicken nugget i'm sorry this
one is actually a mist for me i'm kind
of surprised because i like heat
something about the original chicken
nugget with that celery salt
with the onion powder with the white
pepper it's missing in this
it has heat to it and it's cool but
if you like spicy nuggets you'll like
this but i'm telling you right now
don't mess with the original chicken
nugget flavor this kind of has like a
back heat to it so when you eat it
you don't really taste the heat that
much you don't really taste like the
peppers and stuff until
afterwards as i'm beginning to talk and
my nose gets a little sweaty
there's some heat to it so it's not it's
not like it's
it's not bad if you get it and you like
spicy food
you might like this nugget but in all
honesty i'd rather just get my regular
chicken nugget add a little hot sauce to
it and i'm perfectly fine
this right here though we going back to
this
my bike travis scott
put me on the track homie
the next day okay listen
i'm not saying oh god
oh my god i'm not saying the reason why
my [ __ ] is burning like a thousand
suns
is because of the mcdonald's i ate i
will never ever backstab mcdonald's like
that i ain't no chauncey ass [ __ ] but
right now
coincidence or not it feels like i'm
giving birth to a hot cheeto
the size of jupiter you must become oh
you said you wanted me to vlog so now
i'm vlogging now you got it
your boy is dumping out vlogs like he's
dumping out blood into this toilet
is that my phone hold on
[Music]
what no i'll
i'm i'll okay we'll just wait yeah i'm
running out right now don't worry about
it
yeah i'm ready
you